voilà tu vois tous les jours en photo là
je me demande en fait si c'est des vrais
gens morts qui ont donné leur accord
avant de mourir pour les affiches comme
ça ou si c'est des mannequins qu'on a
payé comme chez les coiffeurs tout va en
fait on voulait savoir une chose les
maqams et qui sont en vitrine
est ce que c'est vrai j'ai pas bien
saisi par mois non messieurs mais je ne
vous connais pas ou filmer j'attends te
pose une question tu veux tu peux vous
répondre ça va on n'est pas des bandits
on n'est pas en train de dévaliser un
magasin on va pas de pitié tpt fleurs en
plastique
réponds moi je te pose une question là
carine tardieu sa loge
mais non c'est toi karine toi tu marques
connues bah ouais
dartau de ma petite cousine marie ça
c'est ma mère mais du coup elle est
vraiment morte depuis
une cliente qui vient d'arriver mon
journal anne alors ça n'a pas l'air
d'aller fort ce cas